[Music]
an experiment to describe your
surroundings of seeing AI seeing AI is
an ongoing research project and in the
app we've also included some of our more
experimental features there you have to
turn those on in settings one of these
is the ability to describe a general
scene when you take a photo the
algorithm detects the objects that it
can see and tries to find the
relationship between them and describe
this in a natural sentence it's still
learning kind of like a kid learns to
speak so as it learns more things in the
world around it the descriptions will
get better over time here's an example
photo I took earlier processing probably
a man sitting on a couch using a laptop
take picture processing a bus that is
parked on the side of the road button
take picture processing probably a box
filled with different types of food on a
table button this is just a glimpse at
the possibilities of artificial
intelligence and I can't wait to see
where this goes in the future Microsoft
logo appears